let me ask you about travis kayla and
maybe a few of the other athletes you've
been involved with so first travis
travis stevens
olympic silver medalist
three-time olympian
2008 2012 2016.
what makes travis stevens great what
makes him so successful what makes him
unique in your mind as an athlete
through all the hardship he had to
overcome
[Music]
through his uh weird looking sayanagi
that
eventually worked out nicely
to the the full richness of his
personality in the context of all the
other great athletes you've coached what
makes him special
his fight
travis has fight and you know the first
time i ever saw travis stevens was in
like recognized him maybe i had seen him
before as a younger boy or something but
like actually recognized him as
i brought a group of young kids to italy
for a competition in a training camp and
it was this program called u-23 elite
and i picked hand-picked 20 kids
to go to this event and it was the first
time i coached an international team
and i had never seen travis fight before
compete train anything and during this
competition
you know he's an 81 kilo player i think
he was maybe like 18 years old um
17 18 years old and
it was a really hard european event and
i think travis won three matches and he
lost two
but what stood out the most to me was
like
the fight he had in him
he was scrapping every fight like he
scrapped hard like he wanted to win more
than any of them right he didn't win but
he wanted to win more and i and i
noticed that right away and then i also
noticed that after he lost his second
match and he was eliminated from the
tournament i saw how disappointed he was
in himself
like he actually thought he was supposed
to beat those people even though he was
like 17 right he's fighting against
grown men that are you know a high level
judo much higher than he was and i said
to him i said hey son like
don't worry man you got a long career
ahead of you like i'm glad you're
disappointed but there's so many things
you don't know and so many skills you
don't have the fact that you were able
to hold your own and scrap like that
like you've got a good future and i
remember calling my friend jason morris
after that tournament and i said hey man
do you ever hear this kid travis stevens
he says no why i said man that kid's got
some fighting him right and i said that
i said that to jason at the time i said
that kid's got some fight in him man
he's pretty talented yeah you know and
that's how it started
um
but so i saw that emma when he was young
but the other thing was
travis like there's not there's no such
thing as hard work to that guy
if you tell him to put his head through
the wall and he'll and that's how he
wins he'll go put his head through the
wall he'll do whatever it takes
for him to do
to achieve success
and he hates
failure
more than he likes winning 100
he always has he punishes himself when
he doesn't do well he makes himself work
harder he goes and you know
just
abuses himself when he doesn't when he
doesn't succeed because he's so
heartbroken and disappointed in himself
so that's a trait that i think all of
the athletes that i work with
like closely though they all had that
same trait they hated losing more than
anything they would they would break
their arm they'd fall on their head you
know they'd rather get hit by a car than
lose a judo tournament yeah you know and
then as a result then they all had fight
and they all were willing to train they
were willing to listen and they would do
anything for victory you know within you
know within the rules i'm not talking
about taking drugs or anything like that
but they would
they'd give a hundred percent of
themselves
for victory and
you know travis was somebody that when
he was down he found a way to do to get
better doing something else if he
couldn't do standing that's when he
started jiu jitsu he couldn't go on his
feet anymore he couldn't stand up and
train i might as well go learn jiu jitsu
and get good on the ground yeah right
because i can you know so he always
found a way no matter what obstacle was
in his way he just went around it
so what about the
interesting to get your perspective
because i know travis's perspective is
the
just the number of injuries
like what do you make of the
perseverance through all the injuries
you had to overcome specifically like
you just observing this creature that
you've coached
i mean he seems to not see the injuries
as a problem he's just like just like
you said head through the wall it's like
what like when i when we were talking
about injuries
he kind of he doesn't even see the
injuries themselves as the problem
because he thinks that the injuries you
know you heal back stronger
i forget the exact quote but he said
like
my body is is now less injury prone than
most of
anyone else
because i've already broken it i've
broken everything and it's just grown
back stronger
like because i asked them something like
do you regret sort of pushing your body
to
all those places that resulted in those
injuries
he was his response was like no i'm
stronger now
so i don't know if that's justification
but that certainly describes a mindset
that yeah head through the wall that
doesn't uh it's almost not
dramatic like look i got this injury
it's so i'm so like brave and special
for overcoming this injury he's just
he's just that's part of the job and he
gets the job done
but like that job involves a lot of
injuries one of the talks i gave travis
and that team at that at that particular
tournament was at the very beginning of
the camp after the tournament i said to
them listen my my vision i shared my
vision with them i said my vision is
you know in seven years because that was
2005. i said in seven years
i want to have a u.s team that steps on
the mat that is ready to kick ass
and in order to get there all of you
guys can be a part of this team and part
of this process but in order to get
there you guys have to be the first ones
to practice you have to be the last ones
to leave because we have to work harder
than the rest of the world because we're
up against all odds i said i am sick of
america being a laughing stock of judo
and being the first round easy match
warm-up for everybody else
i said if you get injured you're not
going to be on the side with with you
know with a ice bag on taking off rounds
and then get back on the mat the next
day and tell me you're okay if you can
train the next day you can train today
so there's no injury the only time
you're leaving this dojo is if the
ambulance has to take you out of here
you know i and i do think subliminally
travis bought into that message and
heard that message then and said if i'm
going to be a champion that's the way
i'm going to do it and he did and he he
embodied it he lived it man there were
many times in europe where i'd say dude
just tape it up go go off to the side
just take the day off like take the rest
of the day off you're beat up you can't
do it he says no no i'm going to tape it
up i'm going to tell you no
you don't need to right now and he said
no sensei i'm doing it i'm you know
the ambulance isn't taking me out it's
just not it's just my wrist it's just my
ankle it's just my it's just my ankle
you know
i love it
yeah what about the so the other really
big thing is you comment on a little bit
is the weight cut
so early in his career he was 81 kg
and that was presumably not so difficult
but later in his career he is 81 kg and
it's becoming more and more difficult so
that's that's the other thing with him
is uh so i've known a lot of
really really tough people at the
highest levels broken by the weight cut
like that can break the toughest mines
and it doesn't seem to have broken him
and he's delivered on it often
on like
insane way cuts
so um
as a coach what do you think about his
particular his mind and the challenge of
the way cut
it was part of his process it was part
of his way of getting ready for battle
suffering yeah it really was
and if i'm gonna suffer this much then
i'm gonna make my opponents pay yeah for
all the suffering that i went through to
get here yeah that was his mindset
um
later on in his career you're right like
a lot of times travis he would never
step on a scale
you know until he got to the tournament
you know and even when he get to the
tournament
like he'd weigh like 90 kilos he'd show
up at the tournament nine kilos over
i'm like
you have to but i never it was just an
expectation of making weight not making
weight was never an option for any of
our athletes and travis knew it and he
said
as a professional my job is to make
weight if i don't make weight he you
know he he was never going to allow that
to happen and he was never going to
allow us to come to him and say hey
i told you you know because he
losing wasn't an option making a weight
wasn't not making weight was not an
option for him ever either but you know
a lot of times he wouldn't even
he'd be nine kilos over on the plane
going over to the tournament and have to
make weight three days later you know
and he didn't break 86 kilos
until the day before the tournament like
he had five kilos over the day before
that was his way but he would do
three workouts you know wake up in the
morning work out then he'd eat then he'd
work out in the afternoon then he'd eat
again then he'd work out again at night
and then he'd reward himself hey i
worked out three times today he'd go
have a you know a mountain dew yeah you
know or a chocolate bar you know and
then he's next morning he's uh you know
back up to 87 and
he would never touch weight
until the morning of lance that that's a
when he that he wasn't on weight for
more than like five minutes
his process would break a lot of people
so the fact that he got the job done is
not just the job done but every single
time he got the job done and i made
those athletes fight
we would fight in paris we would do a
camp for a week double session camp for
a week
he'd be seven kilos over have to fight
the next weekend
we're talking two or three days later
you know so not only did he make the
weight but he did a grueling training
camp twice a day and and then cut weight
and then fought again then did another
camp for a week in double session
training camp and then fought on the
third weekend in a row and our athletes
went through hell you know all of our
athletes went through hell because on
the tour
around the world they fought in every
event they did every camp they fought in
every event whereas most of the other
teams like japan comes in and fights in
paris then they go home you know they
maybe do a camp for three days then they
go home they don't stay in europe for
four or five weeks straight and fighting
every tournament and when you get to
germany the germans skip the french open
they skip the camp in france they're
just getting ready for germany our
athletes already had two competitions
two training camps two with three weight
cuts now and then so they're not a
hundred percent when they fight in
germany but that's all part of the
experience they need the training that
they need that they don't get here in in
this country and all of those were just
preparation for our world championships
or our olympic games so by the time our
athletes got to those tournaments
they felt so strong so rested so like
man this guy
that felt like a monster in germany
feels like nothing today because you're
fully rested now you know
but part of the challenge is because the
american team is smaller
and more i mean just smaller
is um
you know all the different places you go
for to do the weight cut to do the diet
to do the preparation or the recovery
there's like that process changes
every time
so it's you basically have to improvise
a lot oh yeah you show up to a hotel
and how you do the weight cut you don't
know and there's the different weather
conditions it's not
it's like um
so what is it rocky versus drago right
right so you don't have you have to just
improvise and that that's also a
fascinating part of the american judo
story which is like you have to
improvise more well i was funny because
when i it was 1990 and it was at the
goodwill games
right and uh we were it was a u.s
olympic committee type event and so
we're on the bus with the the swim team
and it was me and jason morris on the
american team and we're going to the
judo competition but we're on the bus
with the swim team i'm sorry we're going
to the venue where we're staying you
know i remember being like by ourselves
with no staff no no no manager no coach
we'll just buy ourselves going to fight
in russia right and uh
and the swim team's on there with their
full sweats and their staff and like
their managers and i i heard the lady
the girl go
oh sorry this is 1994 because it was in
st petersburg russia so
i heard the little girl on the team she
goes up the coast she goes coach um
do you think you can send the massage
therapist to my room at 10 a.m you know
i'm feeling kind of jet lagged
i lifted
jason
we looked at his shot like
she
like what the hell is going on here you
know what a difference in yeah sporting
you know different sports within the
same country
you know and but that i mean not to
romanticize things but that you do
represent the spirit of the olympics
when you're kind of
the the
improvisational nature of it because it
it is just you you and sometimes you and
the coach and just
pure guts
and
you against the world with no money the
warrior spirit the warrior spirit
you